I feel very privileged, lucky that I have had a wonderful life...
...and that I have been always allowed to do what I love.
I always say that to me, my role as a designer...
...is to do the very best I can for that woman,...
...to make her feel her very best.
The foundation of his work is great dressmaking and craftsmanship.
Yet, when you see an Oscar de la Renta dress, you'd see the woman first...
...and the dress only complements her beauty and her personality.
Good smile.
I always tell the girls to smile because I hate sad faces.
Oscar has had a great history of dressing first ladies.
Fashion is nonpolitical and nonpartisan.
To me, it's a tremendous privilege...
...that I have been able to dress all these extraordinary ladies.
What counts is now and the immediate future, not the past.
I never look back, I always look forward.
I am lucky that I am part of that movement to understand the power of a woman today.